you asked him before what's what's your
rant now what's getting you really upset
and then we moved on before you answered
is there anything the the level of that
we are we're the country is insane we've
now peaked and you think so oh I think
we'll go further I have said so then we
haven't peaked no we haven't but we're
we're we really are out of our minds and
it something I said a long time ago that
if you thought we were crazy today wait
until you wake up tomorrow amazing and
it's really gotten worse and worse and
worse we're living in what really
there's so much what really we're living
in two different realities we have one
group of people live in one reality and
another group of people live in another
reality completely different realities
separate realities we used to discuss
ideas the Republican Party had their
ideas the Democrats had their ideas some
other people had their ideas but there
was a smaller group had the ideas but
most people were at least had ideas and
were living in the same [__] reality
okay when you take LSD and you're taking
it with a group of people you all better
be on on the same page okay it's kind of
important you don't want three of the
people to be screaming their snakes in
the room you just don't want that you
want all agree there no snakes in the
room so you can move on all right it's
just to me important that democracy
depends on reality it's the it's the
backbone of reality if you don't agree
on reality then what are we voting on
we're voting on your version of reality
are you an
idiot there's one there is reality live
in it it's called tky shitsky don't go
making stuff up you don't get to make
[__] up when you make up stuff when
these idiots are on
TV what they ought to be doing is at any
moment fact check the [__] put a thing
up that's a lie they just made that up
there are no dogs on Pluto got
it do you think that's that was amazing
rant that's and that's a great opening
or closing to whatever show you and it's
actually true but do you
do you I'll tell you what scares me
without is
there everybody's reality now and
because of the power of social media
everybody's reality except the obvious
you know I mean everybody's reality is
different it really is well yeah to a
point to a point but it's really easy to
scare somebody and I think fear is the
fuel of whatever craziness is going on
in the world and we could scare any side
into being afraid of whatever this
reality is going to cause and that's a
that's the biggest problem social media
which I live on I eat breathe yeah you
brought some with you yeah does it not
do you are you on all the platforms yeah
and I post a bit I don't I I I I sto you
said but you know about that I'm not
sending ramps out like
on there's bits and pieces that'll show
up on
um on uh YouTube Instagram Instagram
YouTube uh the Tik Tok I got real short
ones you don't dance uh cuz I'm so good
at it it'll really it'll be people will
go why did he do
comedy
d